both these nominees same perfectly
well-qualified the Senate Majority
Leader wants immediate action on
president Trump's nominations of CIA
director Mike Pompeo for Secretary of
State and CIA deputy director Gina
hospital me the agency but his own party
is putting up blocks I will oppose both
Pompey's nomination and hospital's
nomination Republican Senator Rand Paul
points to hospitals role in the post
9/11 CIA interrogation program that
waterboarded al Qaeda operative Abu
Zubaydah and 9/11 architect Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed to reward somebody to
make them head of the CIA after they're
involved with something so horrendous
and I believe to be illegal I think is a
terrible terrible message to send the
world
Senator Paul noted if fellow Republican
John McCain opposes her nomination there
might be enough votes to block her with
McCain undergoing cancer treatment in
Arizona it's not clear if you will vote
his daughter is cautiously optimistic
McCain might return by summer Democrats
on the Senate panel that will handle
hospice confirmation also have issues
there has been a cover-up with respect
to her background and I used those words
very deliberately but a key member of
the post 9/11 interrogation program
critics called torture defended her the
program was the policy at the time it
came from the highest levels of
government that program stopped attacks
disrupted plots and saved lives the
Republican chairman of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee wants
hearings in April for Pompeo telling Fox
he is optimistic but the process will
not be as smooth as his confirmation for
CIA director I think he got 66 votes in
his last pass-through there'll be
greater scrutiny on this there will
because of just what the position
entails and how it affects how we
project around the world well not a
diplomat by training those who work with
director Pompeo say he would come to the
State Department job with a deep
knowledge of classified intelligence and
regional threats from North Korea to
Iran in Syria no date is on the calendar
for either confirmation hearing